MATTHEW GAUNT: Hi everyone.
My name's Matthew Gaunt.
I'm a developer advocate
on the Chrome team.
Thank you for joining me for
The Modern Workflow for
Developing the Mobile Web, which
I must admit I should've
tried to make that
a bit snappier.
But essentially, where this
talk came from is when you
look at the development
environment for the desktop,
the tools and the way you work
is actually quite mature when
you compare it to
the mobile web.
Whether that be a case of the
frameworks you're using, the
way the flow you're working with
your IDE to the browsers
on your local machine--
one way or another, it's
particularly easy on the desktop.
It lends itself to it.
But when you actually start
working on the mobile web, you
realize a lot this isn't
quite the same.
It's not the case.
Now regardless of what your
specific workflow is, I'd say
you could probably most of the
parts of what you do into
these four categories.
You're going to have a setup
stage, whether you're picking
what tools, what source control,
staging server,
production server, all those
kinds of things.
Then you're going to obviously
have the bulk of the work.
The hard bit.
The developing.
You're going to have
a testing stage.
Whether that be just you
yourself testing in a couple
of browsers, automated
testing, QA teams.
And then obviously once you've
launched you're going to have
the iteration steps.
Hopefully adding new features,
improving what
you've already done.
And essentially what we're going
to be looking at is just
some of the tools that you can
be using in your current
workflow for the mobile web to
hopefully make it a bit more
productive, fit in a bit
easier with what you're
already doing.
So let's start off
with set up.
Now I'm not going to go into
particular frame works you
guys should be using because I
think a lot of that comes down
to personal taste.
But the one thing that you will
need for the mobile web
is obviously either testing on
a device or on emulators and
simulators.
And most people will kind
of opt for emulators and
simulators if it's option
because it's just convenient
to have on your desktop, where
you're already working.
But there are a couple of
caveats that I'd kind of just
raise when you're doing this.
One way or another you should
never treat an emulator a
simulator as a replacement for
an actual real device.
They're great for convenience.
They're fantastic for checking
out what your layout is
actually going to
you look like.
And often it's a case that the
APIs, they're a great test bed
just to make sure that what
you're doing is going to work.
The problem is often performance
is very different
from real life devices.
You look at an Android emulator
it's particularly
slow in comparison to a real
device, whether that be a
high-end or a low-end device.
If you then compare that to some
of the simulators that
you can get, they'll actually
perform really, really well.
And then when it comes to
testing on a real device,
actually performance is really
degraded at certain points.
So I just wanted to make
that point quite clear.
Use them because they're
awesome and
they're really helpful.
But don't treat them
as a replacement
for the real thing.
Now the Android SDK, obviously
there's been a slight
announcement at the keynote.
But essentially when
you go to the web
page there's two options.
One of them's hidden, which
is just the plain SDK.
The other one is the ADT,
Android Developer Toolkit.
ADT will come with Eclipse or
now IntelliJ, as well as the
plug-ins to make it
work with the SDK.
There is the option of just
downloading the SDK, if that's
all you want, to avoid
downloading extra stuff you
won't need or use necessarily.
But once you've downloaded,
the first thing that I'd
encourage you to do is just
make sure you add platform
dash tools and tools
to your path.
Generally, there's going to be
a couple of tools that you're
going to be regularly
relying on.
So just make it a bit easier on
yourself and just add it to
the terminal.
It's something that I think
can quite easily be
overlooked.
And two of those tools I want
to talk about is ADB and
Monitor, which will help you set
up the Android emulator.
So whenever I'm starting
development, if I plug in my
device and it doesn't do what
I'm expecting for whatever
program, ADB is the first port
of call that I go to.
If I run ADB devices, it does
a couple of things.
One, if ADB server isn't running
in the background,
it'll actually start it.
And if I do actually run it,
it doesn't start the server
and there's no devices, then
that's normally a good sign
that something's gone wrong with
the USB to the device.
So just unplug and
plug it back in.
Because ADB is essentially the
bridge between your phone and
your local machine.
And the other tool that you're
going to be regularly coming
in to is Monitor And you can
kind of think of Monitor as
just the one stop shop for all
of the Android tools, or at
least the majority of them.
Now when you open it, it looks
quite daunting at first.
But it's really not that bad.
So if you look over on the left
hand side, you're going
to get a list of devices
connected to that machine.
So there'll be emulators as well
as USB connected devices.
Along the bottom you're actually
going to have logcap.
And what this is is the
log output from
emulators and real devices.
Now if you ever do a hybrid
application with a web view,
if you do consult.log,
the messages will
actually end up in here.
So it might be useful if you
ever start working on
projects like that.
And then the top right it
doesn't necessarily have
anything useful for
web developers.
But it's essentially thread
management, as well as memory
management for native
applications.
So if you ever wonder what
that was, there you go.
So along the top you're going
to actually have options to
access another couple
of tools.
Now the first one is the
Android SDK manager.
If you sit there and say you
want to support Android 2.2
and above, this is where you'll
go to download those
versions of Android.
And then there's the Android
Virtual Device Manager.
Now this is where actually
go to set
up all of your emulators.
So we open that up.
Now the first thing I want to
point out on this screen is
over along the top, you'll
actually have Android virtual
devices and device
definitions.
Now you can imagine scenarios
where something
like the Nexus 1.
It's one device but it's
actually been upgraded through
a couple of versions
of Android.
So realistically you want
emulators for each version of
Android, but to that
device definition.
So that's the difference
between the two.
So if we open up device
definitions, you'll notice
that it's just a long
list of devices.
Along the top, we'll have ones
that are provided by the SDK,
which are the Nexus devices, the
flagship ones from Google.
And then below that we'll
have generic devices.
Because in most cases you can
actually kind of an Android
device out in the wild into one
of these categories for
the most part.
But if you ever find that
there's one device that's
actually causing you grief--
whether it be a particularly
large screen size or something
you're not expecting--
you can actually add in your
own device definition.
Something like the Galaxy S3 or
Galaxy Note where they have
a particularly large screen,
you can add it in.
And you just do it the once
and then you'll set up.
So the Android virtual devices,
it's just a long list
of devices which you
would've set up.
Here's some that I've got.
But if you go in, I'll quickly
step through how
to make your own.
So we'll click on the New along
the right hand side.
It's fairly self-explanatory.
You just need to enter in a
name for your emulator,
something that you recognize.
Then you have the option of
selecting which device.
So which device definition
you want to use.
Here we're going to go
for the Nexus 7.
And then you select
which version of
Android you want to use.
Now there are a couple
of other options.
But for the most part, I don't
think you'd need to
change any of them.
The one thing I would like to
highlight is this option down
at the bottom, which
is Use Host GPU.
Now what this basically enables
the emulator to do is
use some of the hardware power
that you've got on the
graphics card.
Now if your machine supports it,
it vastly improves the use
of the emulator because it
speeds it up quite a bit.
Now it's only available in Ice
Cream Sandwich and above.
But if there's something you're
looking at, definitely
switch it on.
Because if it works on your
machine, like I said, it makes
it a lot more usable.
And then obviously to start it,
is just a case of clicking
on your emulator and
clicking start.
Now, I won't lie.
I have edited the video a little
bit to make this nice
and speedy.
We've all--
our time's valuable.
We need not waste it.
But at the same time, if I just
cut off at this point,
it'd feel a little bit harsh.
So you only have to
do this once.
It may seem like quite a long
process but once you set up
your emulators for devices you
want to support, all you have
to do is come into this tool
and start them up.
For the iOS simulators,
it's a bit easier.
If you have X code installed,
you'll actually just have a
drop-down option for
Open Develop
Tools and then Simulator.
And then within that, once it
started up an iPhone or an
iPad, whichever the last one was
opened, it will allow you
to change the hardware, as
well as the version.
So once you set up the emulators
and simulators, we
move on to development.
Now, I think it's fairly common
that all of us one way
or another will be
using local host.
Now the problem is if you
imagine something like the
Android emulator-- where it's
emulating an entire platform
like it would on a device--
well, that device has
its own local host.
So at which point, developing
on your own machine kind of
starts raising the question of
what happens when I type in
local host.
So I'd like to introduce
your new home
away from home, 10.0.2.2.
Now what this is is just an IP
address that Android have just
left in the emulator.
And it's like a back door.
So what you're saying is, when
I type in this, go to local
host on my actual machine.
But then even if you can get
it on your emulators and
simulators, what about
a real device?
Because normally whenever we try
and do this, it leads to a
bit of pain, tears.
Because obviously you
have to find the IP
address of your machine.
You have to type that
in on the device.
That's assuming that your
network allows it, depending
on if you're in a corporate
network or not.
You then also have the issue
of if you've got a
configuration on your
Apache server.
With subdomains, it doesn't
quite work.
It's not fun.
It's not nice.
So in the dev tools, there's
actually a new tool that we've
added in which is called Reverse
Port Forwarding that
actually allows you to locally
develop on your device.
So you have to enable a flag in
the beta or canary version
of Chrome, which is Enable
Developer Tools Experiments.
And when you do that,
you can actually
go into Chrome Inspect.
And when you open up Chrome on
your Android device, you'll
notice it will come up in the
Chrome Inspect option.
And you'll actually end up with
an inspected item like
you've got down here.
I've already opened up the
developer tools in this case.
So this is the developer tools
for Chrome on Android.
Now because I've enabled the
Experiments flag, I've got
this Experiments menu item.
Now what you'll notice, I've
actually enabled already
Enable reverse port
forwarding.
Now what this is basically doing
is saying, whenever I
type in local host port number
on my mobile device, make it
come onto my machine.
So here you'll see that
I've got a number of
ports already mapped.
Now these don't need to be the
same port numbers, but the
left hand side is essentially
the port number that I typed
in on the device.
And then on the right hand side,
it's essentially saying
local host and then the port
number that's actually running
this machine.
So if I switch over
to this machine.
Now, if I make a typo, you'll
have to excuse me.
So this is Adeeb Azmani's
To Do List app.
But essentially, that's running
off of my local machine.
And just to prove that that's
the case, if I switch back
over to my laptop, I
have the Android
emulator already set up.
And just to keep you on your
toes, if you look at the IO
simulator, it's actually a local
host instead of any kind
of back door.
Now, I'm hoping that's not going
to try and use the Wi-Fi
network it's trying to
find, it looks like,
because it will not work.
Go on.
OK, we'll go back
to that, anyway.
But this introduces a new
problem because essentially,
what we're doing is we've
suddenly got two emulators and
simulators on one device.
Now, normally when I'm
developing, I'll have a mobile
device, just a phone.
I'll have a tablet.
And then, I might have a range
of emulators of varying screen
sizes just for this.
And there's nothing controlling
these things.
They're all individually
working on their own.
So that's why I think it's
starting to get to the point
where you might want to think
about having a device lab.
Now normally, when people say
device lab, you think, oh, I
need to have 30 devices to
warrant that kind of thing.
That's not the case.
If you've got a couple of
devices on your desk, start
thinking about using a piece of
software to help you do it.
And there's a range out there.
So there's Adobe Edge Inspect,
which is essentially, you can
download a Chrome extension.
And then, it'll mirror that tab
that's currently open onto
any devices that have got
the Adobe Edge app
installed and open.
There's Paul Kinlan's
Bootstrapping Your Own Test
Lab, which is a small script,
which will actually open up
the browser on any connected
Android emulators or devices
to the correct URL.
And then, there's also this open
source project, which is
Remote Preview.
Now, all this is doing is it's
a small piece of JavaScript
that's just checking
a particular file.
And essentially, whenever that
URL changes, it sets the URL
on the myFrame in
that web page.
So the idea is that you put all
of your mobile devices to
this one URL.
And then, you've got one central
place so when you
change that URL, it changes
across the board.
So if I switch back to the
mobile device, all I'm going
to do is just change the URL.
Oh, I just did it.
But if I come back over to my
laptop, you'll notice that the
Android browser's already
changing.
And the Safari one will be
changing, should it work,
which it is.
So I'll show you
all what I did.
All I did was edit this one
file, which is url.txt.
And then when I change
that, it starts
affecting all the devices.
So again, I'll show you on the
mobile device because that's
the only one that's
playing ball.
But again, it's just changed
to the To Do List app.
So it's a very simple thing
because it means that should
you ever get to the point where
someone comes up to you
and says, hey, I just need
help on this project.
And you're head deep
in something else.
You've only got to
change one place.
And then all the devices that
are connected already start
filtering through.
And there's also this other
website, opendevicelab.com,
that I wanted to highlight,
which is essentially--
it's a list of device labs
across the world that you can
actually go to and check out.
So if you live near one, find
out what they're using to do
this kind of work and figure out
what pitfalls they've had.
And it might solve some of the
problems that you might be
having in your own workflow.
Another tool I wanted
to talk about
was Responsive Inspector.
Now, this is a third-party
Chrome extension made by Peter
from the Adobe Creative
Cloud team.
And it's just a really nice way
of viewing media queries.
So what you're seeing here is
essentially three different
kinds of media queries, which
is basically saying, a media
query where there's only a
max-width set, which is the
orange one on top.
A media query where you've got
a min and a maximum width
defined, which is the green
one in the center.
And then, the two blue ones on
the bottom are the minimum
width that's been defined.
Now, what this tool is really
great for is if you actually
click on one of these media
queries, you'll notice the
browser in the background
snapping to those particular
media queries.
So it's a really nice, easy way
of, A, viewing what the
media queries are doing, and
secondly, just interacting
with them in the same way.
But you also have the option
of going to the ruler-- the
measurement across the top--
and forcing the browsers to snap
at a particular width,
which is really nice if you've
got media queries that are
overlapping and you want to
ensure that things aren't
actually conflicting.
And the last feature which I
really am a fan of is this CSS
option at the side.
Now, if you click on this for
one particular media query,
it'll actually take you to the
CSS that's essentially that
media query.
Now, I found this tool really
useful for, A, if I have a
compilation step with perhaps JS
optimizing CSS, et cetera.
I'll check whether the actual
version of the site I'm
looking at has those media
queries in it.
And secondly, if I'm having
problems, something's not
quite right, normally it's the
case that the CSS isn't quite
doing what I'm expecting,
something's not
in the right order.
And in which case, this CSS
option is really easy.
So then, we come onto testing.
Now, raise your hand if you use
the dev tools in Chrome,
the Firebug in Firefox,
Safari dev tools.
Who here uses them?
Now, keep your hand up if you'd
actually be quite happy
to live without them.
And they're just gone.
Have no option to them.
There's a couple of hands,
which I'm surprised at.
But the problem is with the
mobile web, we don't have
those, right?
They're a separate device.
They're separate browsers.
And generally, the tools
are only just
starting to get there.
But it's not on all platforms.
If you look at something like
the Android web view, there
are no dev tools for that.
You can't hook into them.
So one of the tools that you'll
actually find that most
people use is this tool called
Weinre, which is
web inspector remote.
That's what it stands for.
Some people call it "Weiner."
But essentially, what it does
is you put a little bit of
JavaScript in your web page.
And then, if the APIs are
actually there, what it'll do
is it'll actually use some of
the developer tool APIs to
then give you a remote
dev console that
you'll see on the left.
And the nice thing with this is
you can actually edit the
HTML, edit the CSS, play around
with the JavaScript
console, just like you would on
your actual local machine.
If you wanted to play around
with this, I'd strongly
encourage just check out
debug.phonegap.com.
It's actually a running
server of this.
And what's really nice, as well,
is if you think about
cloud-based testing, you
can actually put
the script in this.
And if the server is actually in
a local, public place, you
can remotely debug a
cloud-based system.
And then, we come onto something
like MIHTool, which
actually uses Weinre.
So it's a native iOS
application.
And essentially, when you
actually load up a web page,
it'll already start
up Weinre for you.
It'll give you a URL, and
you can just access
it on a local network.
If you go and use it on an
iPad, it goes one step
further, and it actually gives
you Weinre inside the
application.
So you can actually debug there
and then on the device.
But the really nice thing with
MIHTool, as well, is it's
actually added a couple of
features which you can't get
in Safari dev tools.
So it'll actually show you the
composited layers as well as
the draw count.
So if you're finding performance
might be a bit of
an issue, you can actually start
using this to find out
what's going on.
I've already briefly touched on
this, but this is the cloud
based testing idea.
So I imagine a lot of you are
familiar with Browser Stack
and Source Labs.
And there are a number
of other services.
But Browser Stack comes from
the idea of manual testing.
You open up a couple of
simulators, emulators.
And you get to play around
with them and
interact with them.
Now, Device Anywhere comes from
a slightly different idea
of real-time devices that you're
actually getting screen
captures from or
web cams from.
Now, the nice thing with this,
if you're having a particular
problem, perhaps a bug in the
JavaScript or something on one
particular device, this is a
nice way of you can actually
gain access to that.
Because it comes with all the
OEM tweaks rather than an
Android emulator, where it's
just stock Android.
And then, Source Labs comes
from more of an automated
testing background.
So let's talk about
automated testing.
There's a couple of different
ways of doing it.
There's obviously unit tests.
And if you develop unit
tests, you may have
them running locally.
But you could also
start looking at
running them in the cloud.
I was recently playing around
with a couple of grunt tasks
for Source Labs and Browser
Stack, which actually take my
unit test and QUnit, and run
them on whatever simulator I
tell it to.
But then, there's also
test scripts.
If anyone's ever worked with a
QA team, you know that quite
often, they'll run scripts.
They'll follow certain steps
and see what the output is.
So you can actually start doing
this in browsers with
something called WebDriver.
Now, what WebDriver allows you
to do is essentially interact
with the browser and control
it in some ways and perform
certain tasks.
And the way you can do this is
you're essentially using a
small, little JavaScript and
nodeJS, as well as a number of
other platforms.
But I'll go through a brief
example in nodeJS.
So here's just a brief
configuration for a browser
that I want Source Labs
to launch for me.
So essentially, we're just
saying, I want an Android
tablet with version 4
of Android running.
And then, we have a small
bit of code, which is
just setting up.
So we're saying to the
WebDriver, I'm going to use a
remote connection
to Source Labs.
And then, down at the bottom,
you'll notice I've got
initialization step, which is
just saying, I want the
browser of Android tablet.
I'm passing in a GET Request
to the URL local host.
And that's because a lot of
these services will enable you
to make a local tunnel
from your
machine to their services.
And then, I'm saying,
take a screen shot.
After that, check
the navigation.
And then, quit.
So if we look at taking a
screen shot, the code is
surprisingly simple.
You literally just say,
take a screen shot.
You get a call back with
a 64-bit encoded image.
And then here, I'm just
using the file
system API to save it.
And then, checking navigation,
here, I'm just saying, find
the link inside an element
with the ID blog.
Click that element.
And then, afterwards, check what
the actual URL of that
current page is and make sure
that it's what I'm expecting.
And I've done a full example
which you can actually take
and run yourself, which you'll
pass in an array of browsers
that you want to test on.
It will then set the orientation
to portrait.
It'll take a screen shot, which
is what you're seeing on
the right hand side.
It doesn't just do the
bit of the screen.
It does the entire thing, if the
body is set up correctly
for the correct height.
And then, once it's actually
done that, it'll check the
navigation, and then flip the
orientation to make sure that
the media queries are actually
happening as they should be.
And then, the check navigation
is just a small example of
things that you can do.
But WebDriver, you can do a
number of other things.
You can execute JavaScript
directly into the page.
You can also, with Source
Labs, actually watch the
entire recording of
the test running.
So if there's certain things you
want to do in terms of--
click this element, and watch
the DOM be manipulated, the
visibility is changing on
certain elements, or sizing's
getting tweaked--
you can actually just sit there,
tell WebDriver to do
this, and then watch
the video that's
captured on Source Labs.
And the other thing I wanted to
talk about was networking.
Now, if we are just working on
our local machine in our
office, we're going to have
a nice, beefy internet
connection, hopefully.
But obviously, mobile users
aren't going to have
this all the time.
They may be at home
on a nice Wi-Fi.
They might be on 2G in the
middle of the woods with
barely any connection at all.
So there's a couple of tools
you can use to actually
throttle the local network.
So here's an example of using
the link conditioner on OS X.
So on the left hand side
is when it's off.
On the right hand side
is when it's on.
And this is, I think,
an EDGE connection.
Now, the really nice thing with
this tool is here, you
can see things are slowly
getting loaded.
It's not particularly
performant.
But if you have a page like this
where you've got a dark
background, and you're actually
using some dark text
on one particular item while a
background image is loading
which is light, what you can
actually find is you can just
set a background color
which is light.
And then suddenly, people can
actually read the text,
whereas before they wouldn't
have been able to.
And plus, it gives you an
indication of what's actually
happening and what your
user is seeing.
So then we have the live step.
We've actually launched
the product.
It's out there.
It's in the world.
People are using it.
And it's awesome.
But one way or another, through
your development
cycle, you will have made
certain assumptions.
We all do it.
We all get to the point where
we need to do it.
But one of the things that you
always have to make, and it's
kind of a tough call,
is break points.
Where do you decide where to
change the look and feel of
your web app to actually fit
the range of devices?
And Google Analytics has this
little, hidden nugget of gold.
And you can actually find out
what the screen resolution of
the mobile devices that are
actually visiting your site.
And the nice thing with this
is you can actually realize
that you can probably support
80% of your users with just a
small number of configurations.
Now, these are metrics that
are actually taking into
account the screen density.
So it's the same as what
your CSS and media
queries would be seeing.
But what's even more
interesting, if you look at
number one, you'll notice that
the height, I think, is 768.
Whereas if you look at number
four, it's 720.
So it's only about 40
pixels different.
But if you were to say, I'm
going to put my break point at
768, which I think is an iPad,
and then everything below that
gets the mobile experience, well
suddenly, that 720 pixel
width device is actually getting
the phone UI rather
than what you've already
designed for a tablet.
And that's a simple change.
That's just changing it
to 40 pixels less.
So at that point, you're
actually giving a better
experience to a wider
audience.
And then, there's
also page speed.
You can actually change the
configuration so you're only
filtering on mobile and
tablet traffic.
So you can actually see what
users are getting in the wild.
Now, the nice thing with this
is you can find out, A, if
what your testing has been doing
is actually matching
what users are getting.
But on the other side of it if,
if you're sitting there
saying, I want to improve this
and you actually start making
steps to do it, you can confirm
that it's working
through this.
And ultimately, this is all
going to feed back into what
you do for the next project or
whatever new features you come
to develop.
Because ultimately, it's going
to influence what your
decision's going to be in terms
of what emulators you
test on, what platforms
you test on.
It's going encourage you to look
at the way you're going
to continue your development.
If you realize that it's too
many device to test against,
perhaps you want to find out
another way of doing it.
Testing, hopefully if you've
started playing with automated
testing, you're going to have
an idea of what works well,
what doesn't work well, what
things you could have really
easily scripted that later
became a bigger problem.
And then live, well, again,
mobile is never
going to sit still.
It's always changing.
So at that point, you're going
to be constantly iterating
over what you want to support
and how you're going to
support it.
And this is the main point of
the mobile web, right, is it's
still relatively new.
Things are changing
constantly.
And these are just some of the
tools you can use today in
your workflow.
But there's nothing to say
that throughout your
development of your next
project, you're going to see
more tools come out.
They're going to change
the way you work,
or make things easier.
Maybe even the case that you
guys are actually making the
tools for this.
So I hope you enjoyed my talk.
That's all I wanted to say.
[APPLAUSE]
MATT GAUNT: So I think we've
got about 10 minutes for
questions if anyone
has anything.
We've got a mic there, if
you want to queue up.
AUDIENCE: I've had the very
unpleasant experience of
trying to develop on a 12 hour
overseas flight and realizing
that to be able to tether an
Android device to a laptop,
you have to be able to hit App
Engine in the cloud, which
doesn't work if you don't have
an internet connection.
Is there anything that's being
done to improve that?
MATT GAUNT: So what I demoed was
the actual local host from
your desktop machine
onto a device.
AUDIENCE: So with no network
connection, you can do remote
port forwarding, and everything
will work?
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
The only caveat is if you need
to pull a couple of local host
services, you do need
to define each port.
That's the only caveat
that I found.
So what happens is when you
actually unplug your device,
it'll still save which
ports you have
set up for that device.
So you can actually set up
multiple ones and it'll work.
AUDIENCE: OK.
MATT GAUNT: So you'll need
to get beta for Chrome.
And this feature isn't added
to it yet, but it will be
coming very soon.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
MATT GAUNT: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
MATTHEW GAUNT: Hi.
AUDIENCE: I'm a bit
curious about
the development workflow.
Today, many of us are sitting
in our text editor.
And we're sitting, when we're
making a change to our web
applications, we're sitting
with the inspector.
And today, we saw that the
Android guys, they got Android
studios to give this fully
integrated development
experience.
Is there any plans on bringing
that to web?
Because today, it's kind
of an isolated world.
I'm sitting in my editor.
I'm going to my inspector,
trying to memorize values,
going back to my editor
to save them.
MATT GAUNT: So Paul Irish is
actually doing a talk on dev
tools in Chrome.
And there's a load of new
features that I think are
addressing exactly
that problem.
That's going to be exactly
the same for this.
So yeah, I definitely recommend
checking that talk out.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
MATT GAUNT: Thank you.
Cool, thank you, everyone.
My slides will be up with a load
of the other IO stuff.
I haven't put a link up yet.
But follow me on Google+ or
Twitter, and I'll be tweeting
them and everything else.